if you are concerned about the problem
of narrow range of ideas in media in the
United States with too few owners and
the horrific consolidation that we've
seen over the last 15 or 20 years it is
about to get a lot worse and oligarchy
is when a small group of people has
control of either a country or an
organization or in industry or an
institution and today I need to talk to
you about the institution of news media
in the United States you might remember
that Comcast bought MSNBC Universal
which includes MSNBC meaning Comcast
owns MSNBC one of the few cable news
channels and now we have learned over
the weekend that AT&T is going to buy
CNN and more because they've actually
reached a deal to acquire Time Warner
for more than 80 billion dollars if this
is successful it's still an if but it
appears to be moving forward at least
for now AT&T would gain control of some
major brands including HBO including
warner brothers entertainment and CNN
last year 18c already acquired directv
for 48 and a half billion dollars I
cannot possibly overstate the importance
of this now you might say David I don't
care about news media I don't watch TV I
care about the environment and climate
change you cannot separate the two
public willingness to commit money and
resources to fighting climate change
depends on what people know or think
they know about climate change which is
informed by what corporate media and
what is corporate media influenced by
the huge amount of advertiser money that
pours in and of course media being
mostly run by a few large corporations
if you care about income inequality
public motivation to pass laws to reduce
inequality depends on what people think
about income inequality if people don't
understand why it's bad for our
economy and society to have a high
degree of income inequality why would
there cater care to change it and of
course corporate media is not explaining
to people why income inequality is bad
so if your reaction is that let me do
whatever they want i'm not living in the
news media world here's my issue
whatever your issue is it is dictated by
media coverage of the issue and how
media is owned and funded no matter what
issue you care about Pat this story is
the stuff of nightmares I was actually
watching some CNN and of course they
were kind of reluctant to speak on this
merger yeah it was a brian Stelter
reliable sources yes spent about five
minutes talking about this and he said
that CNN would keep their journalistic
integrity the course anyone really
believe that I mean they're just going
to negate certain stories if it has any
conflict of interest with their sponsors
yeah and and you know sometimes you'll
see that media will cover a story about
their parent company and they'll say in
the interest of disclosure X company is
the parent company of this network and
then they go on to to talk about the
story in whatever terms but the the
total narrowing of what issues are even
acceptable is only going to get worse
with this and Internet service providers
have expanded their holdings they find
themselves when an Internet service
provider buys content creators all of a
sudden they're competing with companies
like Netflix for example and you can see
the obvious incentive that it would
create for for example ATT buys HBO they
want people to subscribe to HBO rather
than netflix because AT&T would make
money by people subscribing to HBO so
they can make changes to their internet
service for example to make HBO more
preferable to Netflix maybe netflix
doesn't stream as well for example the
idea would be that net neutrality would
prevent all of this from happening but
when you have total what's called
vertical integration that you own the
entire means of production and
distribution it is very difficult for
government to effectively police that
and beyond that it's more of a concern
when you think about the manufacturing
of public opinion
that's able to be done by so few
companies you've gotta wake up right
this is something again we're with
President Trump we have no chance
pro-corporate Supreme Court justices
lawsuits against media which Donald
Trump is said he would do that is very
different then center left center right
Hillary Clinton appointing some
relatively center left or left Supreme
Court justices with Hillary there's no
automatic improvement but it's likely
not going to get worse and maybe maybe
we can do something about it as
consumers comcast controls MSNBC AT&T on
the verge of controlling CNN welcome to
the future of media and I know for many
in our audience I don't have to to paint
the picture this clearly but you have to
support independent media right I mean I
know it's tough but you need to choose
to go the other way and do things like
being a member of our show we're talking
about pennies a day here okay and you're
seeing what's happening I've been uh
telling you about media consolidation
for years I've been telling you about
the narrow source of media stories and
saying we have to support independent
media if it's not this show support some
other show we've got to do it and you
can use coupon code hey tree at 40
that's h eight ER iot 40 when you sign
up for membership at david pakman.com
slash membership to get a discount I
don't care how much you pay we need by
in because this is the stuff of
nightmares that we are seeing Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
try-on to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / tdps I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses well the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the come
part of my own home pick the one I like
the most and then Warby Parker put my
prescription lenses in there for me a
lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing